Okay. So, um, today we will look at
Jewish history. So, let's review what we
learned about Jewish history so far.
Now, remember that for most of human
history, the um, Middle East um, has
been the wealthiest part of the world.
And as we discussed before, the Levant
especially Jerusalem
is the center of the world because it it
connects all the major civilizations.
Okay, you have Egypt, Anatolia,
Mesopotamia, and over here you have the
Persians and over here is the
Mediterranean. Okay, as you can see,
basically all roads lead to Jerusalem.
So, whoever controls Jerusalem controls
the major trade access point, which is
the most profitable part of an empire.
And so for these empires, it's always
been a problem of how to keep Jerusalem
under control because Jerusalem, whoever
controls Jerusalem, can always choose to
switch sides, right? So if Mesopotamia
controls Jerusalem, what the Egyptians
will do is bribe uh Jerusalem to switch
sides. And this keeps on going over and
over. And they tried many different
techniques on how to control Jerusalem.
The Babylonians tried to take captives
hostage and that didn't really work as
well. So the Babylonians decided to
destroy Jerusalem. Okay. And with it uh
the Israeli identity became splintered
and scattered.
Um and this is the Babylonian Empire.
But eventually what will happen is that
the Babylons will be conquered by the
Persians
and the Persians will adopt a new
technique to control Jerusalem which is
divide and rule. They will create the
Jewish identity implanted in Jerusalem
and that will create conflict the locals
and the Jews will not be forever loyal
to Persia because they are a foreign
entity within the Levant and only uh by
swearing loyalty to Persia can they
maintain control over the Levant and in
return the Persians will give the Jews
financing to build their second temple.
So at this point in history, a Jewish
identity emerges and there are three
pillars to the identity that continues
even today. Okay. So the first pillar is
they become a monotheistic religion
which believes that Yahweh is the only
God and they're the chosen people of
Yahweh because Yahweh had a covenant
with Abraham.
Yahweh promised Abraham that your people
will control the promised land. Okay?
And the promised land extends from the
Nile in Egypt to the Euphrates in
Mesopotamia. Okay? That is a promised
land. That's the first pillar. The
second pillar is the Jews must follow
the law of Moses because the law of
Moses is the law of God, the ten
commandments, right? The law of Moses
over time um will be divided into the
Torah which is the written law and the
atonement which is the oral law. And the
Torah is basically the five books of the
Bible. The first five books of the
Bible. The third pillar is to use the
Bible as the collective memory of the
people. Okay. So they um Jews believe
the Bible what happened to the Bible is
literal. It is actually what happened
and by believing that the Bible is
literal and true then you become a Jew.
Okay. And that's why the Jewish identity
um is very flexible. Okay. So um at this
point in history uh when the Jews swear
loyalty to Persia there are some
characteristics that will change over
time. The first major characteristic is
that the center of worship is in
Jerusalem and the second temple. Okay.
So if you're a Jewish person, you must
make animal sacrifices to uh Yahweh and
therefore the uh seducies. These are
hereditary priests. They are the ones
who control the religion. Then there's
very strict laws that govern how people
behave. So for example, you must rest on
Sabbath. You also cannot marry outside
your religion. You must be circumcised.
Okay. So the there are all these um
restrictions on how people behave.
Over time what will happen is that the
Jews will expand across the world. Um a
lot of Jews will work as mercenaries in
a great army as he conquers Persia. And
as um the helenic world comes into
being, Jews will move around for
economic opportunities, right? They'll
work as officials, they'll work as
artisans, they work as traders,
merchants. And so they're scattered
around [snorts]
uh the helic world. And as we discussed
at this point in history, the three
major cultures that we've looked at, the
Jewish culture, the Greek culture, and
the Persian culture will merge together
in a process we call synchronization.
And that gives birth basically to
western civilization.
Um unfortunately what happens is that
over time because the Jerusalem is so
important and because the Jews believe
they are special people who only worship
the one true god that will cause
conflict with the Greeks. Okay. The
Greeks also are very chauvinist
chauvinistic, very uh proud people who
believe their culture is superior and
quite honestly a lot of Jews will
convert to the Hellenistic uh lifestyle.
Okay. But this causes conflict and
ultimately this will culminate in
something called the Makabian revolt
where a certain group of Jews decide to
rebel against the Greeks. And even
though they're minority, even though
most Jews actually do not support them,
because of their religious conviction,
because of the will of God, they will
triumph and they will establish
uh the Makabian kingdom. And this
victory is celebrated today in something
called the Hanukkah festival. Okay,
Hanukkah. And that's a celebration of
the Makabes revolt against the Greeks.
And the reason why is the Greeks wanted
uh the Jews to
celebrate their religion as well. They
wanted to turn the second temple um into
a a site to worship Greek gods. And so
so the fanatical Jews rebelled against
that. Okay.
All right. Um but this kingdom of the
Mcabes will not last very long.
Um again the problem is that Jerusalem
it is the nexus of empires and so what
will happen is the Romans will come and
take control over this area and the
Romans actually worse than the Greeks.
The Romans are even more chauvinistic
uh more discriminatory towards the Jews
and this will launch three major wars
between the Romans and the Jews. the
entire Jewish diaspora revolt against
the Romans and this will lead to many
many Jews being massacred because the
Romans are a vicious people. In 70, the
year 70 they burn down the second temple
to destroy the morale of the Jews. And
because they destroy the second temple,
this causes a shift in the Jewish
religion. Because remember at this point
in history, the second temple is a site
of Jewish worship. This is the house of
God. This is where Yahweh lives. Okay?
So when when the second temple is
destroyed, what happened is that the
Jews or many Jews will choose to convert
to Christianity. Okay? Because remember
we discussed how Paul created
Christianity as a mechanism for Jews to
still be Jews but at the same time be
Roman as well. Okay, that's the idea of
the Christian religion. But those who
stay become much more fanatical. In
fact, they develop a very messianic
esquetological attitude meaning the end
of the world is coming. God is coming to
destroy the Romans and we must show our
loyalty to God. And so they keep on the
fight even though they've lost the war
against the Romans. They will go into
the Arabian desert where they will
incubate a new religion called Islam and
they will prophesize the coming of the
Messiah who turn out to be Muhammad.
Right?
Um so at this point in history the Jews
must leave Jerusalem because the Romans
basically kicked them out and their uh
religion will splinter into into many
different factions. But the major
characteristic is that they've gone from
temple worship to the worship of uh
their law. Okay, the law of Moses. And
so the rabbis come into power. Before it
was the seduces, the priests who control
the temple who are in charge. Now it's
the rabbis. The rabbis are basically the
Pharisees, those who teach the oral law
of Moses. Okay? So they become the new
elite in the Jewish diaspora. And um
um so as we discussed a lot of Jews at
this time convert to Christians. All the
early Christians
were Jews. Okay.
Um and as we discussed what will happen
is those Jews who are almost they will
escape into the desert and they will
incubate Islam and eventually Islam will
conquer the world. Now this at this
point they feel as though they've
achieved the messianic age and
they have returned to the uh to
Jerusalem. Now the Jews believe that in
the mezanic age the Messiah will come
lead them to victory uh bring all the
Jews back to Jerusalem and build the
third temple and usher in the mezzanic
age. Okay. And that's what they believe
happened. And so this is the alastic
mosque in Jerusalem and this is meant to
be the third temple. Over time what
happened is they would change it to
become a center of Islamic worship. But
in the beginning it was really the third
temple. And so at this point a lot of
Jews convert to Islam as well because
they think that Muhammad is the Messiah.
Okay. So a lot of Jews are converted to
Christianity and Islam but there are a
lot of Jews who do not and they settle
throughout the world. Okay, let's look
at Europe at this point. So what's
happening in Europe is that Europe
becoming more and more Christian but the
Jews are allowed to stay and what will
happen over time is that they will be
persecuted, massacred and expelled from
many different places
um in Europe. I'm not sure if you can
see this map clearly, but um the
uh circles, okay, are places where there
was at least one Jewish expulsion. So,
this is a terrible time for the Jews
because they settle in on a place,
they're trying to practice religion, and
then
um after they've settled in, they're
expelled by the people. So, why does it
happen? Okay. Well, what's happening is
that the Jews come to an arrangement
with the European nobility. Okay. And
there's a deal. There's a contract.
That's not written down, but it's
understood. Basically, what the Jews
agree to is they become slaves to
nobility. Okay? Because in the Christian
religion, you are not allowed to charge
interest. You're not allowed to make
bank loans to peasants and charge
interest. But that's the most profitable
business you can get into, right? So you
as as no can't do it. What do you do?
Well, you get the Jews to do it for you.
But not only that, but you get the Jews
to also manage your property. Jews are
actually very good at industry and
trade. There's a Jewish diaspora, right?
So the Jews make very good merchants
because they're able to access different
networks around the world. That's very
important if you're if you're the elite.
Also the Jews can make loans to you for
wars and stuff. Okay. And Jews are very
good at finance. They're very good at
medicine. Okay. So the Jews become very
indep independent. They become a very
important part of the European economy.
Okay. And the last reason which is the
most problematic is that the Jews are
kept around as a scapegoat. Okay. So you
know in our society we have poor people.
Why? to put fear into people, right? If
you don't work hard in school, if you
don't make a lot of money, you end up
like poor and homeless, right? Well, in
Catholic Europe, remember the Catholic
Church is in charge at this point. The
Catholic Church wanted to keep Jews
around to scare the Christians and say,
"Hey, if you don't believe in Jesus,
you're you end up like the Jews." Okay?
And so what happens is that this
arrangement is fine when the economy is
good. But what happens when the economy
is bad? What happens when people are
angry? The Jews get blamed, right?
Because the Jews are the ones who are
lone sharks. The Jews are the ones who
killed Jesus. The Jews are the ones who
are causing all the spiritual pollution,
right? And so this is the implicit
contract made between the Jews and the
European nobility. you're allowed to
stay and make a lot of money, but when
we need a scapegoat, you get blamed and
you have to leave, okay? Or possibly get
massacred as well. So, it's a terrible,
terrible deal for the Jews, but they
keep it because they want to practice
their religion, okay?
All right. So um there's one place in
Europe that is very friendly towards the
Jews and this is actually the wealthiest
part of Europe. It's Spain. Okay. At
this point it's controlled by the
Muslims. And remember the difference
between the Muslims and the Catholics is
the Catholics persecute the Jews because
they think that the Jews killed Jesus.
But the Muslims don't believe that. The
Muslims believe that the Jews, the
Christians, uh the Muslims are all one
big family. Okay? and they are all
descendants of Abraham. So the Jews and
the Christians are treated very well in
Spain and Jews rise up very high within
the Alanderus system. Okay? Because
they're um very literate. They know the
Bible very well. The Bible is a holy
book. They have they have connections to
the Jewish diaspora around the world. Um
and they are um um extremely good at
finance. Okay. So the Jews prosper in
this region. The problem is that over
time this region will be be reconquered
by the Christians and
now the Christians will continue to
persecute the Jews and force Jews to
convert. Okay, so this is when the Jews,
Christians and Islams get very get along
very well in Spain. Okay. But in 1492
um
the spa the spa uh the Spanish will
expel the Jews from Spain. You either
convert or you leave. Okay. And a lot um
convert and a lot go off to the Ottoman
Empire. Okay. And this was a traumatic
event in Jewish history because they
were extremely well established in
Spain. They felt they were Spanish and
now suddenly they lost everything. Okay.
Now a lot did convert um and this caused
this shism a divide sism within the
Jewish religion. Um those who converted
and those who refused to convert now
became bitter enemies. Okay.
[snorts]
Okay. So what will happen now is a lot
of Jews choose to settle in the Polish
Lutheran Commonwealth which is a new uh
nation and because it's a new nation
they need a lot of people. So uh what
they will do is they will have extremely
tolerant policy policies towards the
Jews. You're allowed to practice your
own religion. So a lot of Jews around
the world settle in the Polish Lutheran
Commonwealth and again they thrive. They
do extremely well. But the problem is
that this area can be easy easily
invaded and because it becomes more
wealthy more people start to invade it
from Sweden, from Russia and so war
breaks out and a lot of Jews get killed.
So it just gets worse and worse for the
Jews. When they think they finally found
a home, they have to suffer this
persecution. So all these all this
history creates a major crisis of faith
among Jewish people. Okay.
And the three big questions is
the first law in the Jewish religion is
do not worship false idols. That's the
first law of the ten commandments. So
why is it that Jews can convert to
Christianity and Islam and not suffer
any consequences? Okay. And why are so
many Jews converting? If Yahweh is a
true God and Yahweh demands complete
obedience to him,
why is it okay to convert? Okay, that's
that that's a problem. Second problem is
what did you what did Jews do wrong
exactly
to be persecuted and massacred like
this? Yeah. Okay. Jew some Jews convert
to Christianity and Islam but go punish
them man. Why are the Jews who are loyal
to Yahweh punished? That makes no sense.
Okay. And the third big question is if
Yahweh promised the Jews a homeland
called a promised land, why don't they
have it? Why are they kicked out? For
hundreds of years, despite all the
persecution, despite all the trauma,
they've stayed loyal to Yahweh. So why
is this happening? This creates a crisis
of faith. Okay? And so whenever there's
a crisis of faith, Jews believe it is
the end times. The world is coming to
the end and the Messiah is coming. Okay?
So at this point in history about the
year 1600 there's this is heavy
anticipation of the coming of Messiah
and so when will happen is that one man
named Zai Zevi who is born in Ottoman
the Ottoman Empire he will declare
himself the Messiah okay and Zai Zevi is
the equivalent of Jesus in the Jewish
religion now we don't actually know much
about him and the reason why is that
um
what we know about him. A lot of
information was written by his enemies
uh the rabbis, his followers are pretty
secretive. Okay. But um one thing
happened is this. Whenever you have a
messiah come, what the messiah does is
he's essentially a revolutionary. He's
trying to overthrow the social order.
Okay? And his major concern is why are
Jews being persecuted like this? And his
answer is because we're not practicing
the true faith. What we have are all
these laws created by the rabbis. But
who are the rabbis? The rabbis are just
a corrupt elite like all every like
every priest class before. They're like
the Catholic Church, right? The Catholic
church is a hierarchy and so over time
they become extremely corrupt. The
rabbis don't really suffer that much
persecution, right? So when Jews are
massacred and persecuted, guess what
guys? It's usually not the Jewish elite
that's massacred and persecuted, right?
And also the rabbis are the ones who are
helping the European elite
persecute the Jews, right? Because it is
the rabbis that control the Jews and to
maintain control of the Jews, they come
into these unfair agreements within Jew
with the European nobility. So for Zevi,
the real problem is a hierarchy within
the religion. The real problem are these
laws that don't make any sense. Don't
eat pork. So the Sabbath, right? Rest on
um Saturday, you're not going to convert
to other religions. Doesn't make any
sense. What should matter is your faith
in God. If we are a people,
if we are a family born of Abraham and
we share one blood, then who cares what
you dress like, what you look like?
We're all one blood. The faith in your
heart should is what matters. And also
there should be no hierarchy.
[snorts] People should be free to choose
their religion. People should be free to
choose their own lifestyle. People
should be free to choose their own laws.
If God loves us, if there's a divine
spark in us, then we should know what is
right and what is wrong. Okay? So there
are three things that he does that's
really important. The first and most
important thing is he proposes an
egalitarian society where men and women
are all equal where there's no more
hierarchy where the rabbis are not above
you because
um the law doesn't exist anymore. Okay.
What matters is your relationship to
God. So in many ways he's a proto
liberal and a protocommunist.
Okay. He believes that the system
designed as it is where um you must obey
the rabbi and we must await for the
coming of Messiah who will take us back
to Jerusalem. It's meant to defend the
status quo. It's meant to make the Jews
slaves to the nobility. Okay? So he's
very much a proberal and procommunist
and we'll discuss his influence on
modernity next class. Okay? That's the
first thing I want you guys to remember.
Second thing I want you guys to remember
is that he ultimately converts to Islam.
Okay? So when he announced himself as
Messiah, a million Jews follow him
because he's preaching a message of
liberation,
of equality,
of freedom. And so a million Jews follow
him. But then he does something that's
really weird which confuses people which
is he's supposed to as a Messiah take
them to war against the Ottoman Empire
and restore Jerusalem to the Jewish
nation.
But when he's confronted by the Sultan,
the Sultan basically says to him the
turban or your head. The turban means
you convert to Islam or I will cut your
head off. Si converts to Islam. And I
was like why did he do that? And the
reason why he did that is you you need
to understand his Messiah who's come to
redeem the Jews, right? You got millions
of Jews who in the centuries have
converted to Christianity to Islam.
According to the rabbis, these people
will burn in hell. But if they're all
part of one family, if they all have the
divine spark, then they must be redeemed
as well before we can have heaven on
earth. So, Zabia Zevi what he does is by
converting he sacrificing himself just
like Jesus sacrificing himself on the
cross to redeem us from the original
sin. He is now redeeming the Jews all
Jews from the original sin of
conversion.
Okay? And so by doing this he's saying
it's okay to convert guys. In fact I've
absolved you of the original sin with
God. So now you can now be close with
God and therefore
you don't have to follow the laws
anymore. Okay, the messianic age has
come because you are the messianic age
now. So last thing he suggests is the
idea of justification by sin. Okay, and
again the mis there's been a lot of
misinterpretation that this just means
that oh it's okay to uh break the laws
now. Okay. In fact, um, Zevi, you know,
he converts to Islam. He eats pork and
he's he has a lot of wallet sex. Okay.
And so he breaks a lot of these laws.
And but what Zevi is really saying is
that in the meant age laws don't apply
because we all have the wisdom in
ourselves to follow our own laws. And by
breaking the laws, what you're showing
is your true faith in the Messiah, your
true faith in God, your true faith in
yourself.
Okay? because you're no longer
constrained by rebetic authority. Are we
clear? Okay. So, um this is the idea of
Zab Zi.
What happens when he converts is most
choose not to follow him. Most choose to
go back to the rabbis who who are his
enemies. But there are 300 families who
choose to convert with him. And these
families are called the Doma. And guess
what happens?
The Domai will eventually come to
control Turkey. Okay, this is Mustafa
Anatkurk who was the founder of the
Republic of Turkey and he's a Domai
guys. Okay, so you can argue that today
the Domai control Turkey.
All right. So the Jews believe in
reincarnation and 50 years after Zeb's
death, okay, a new person named Jacob
Frank will emerge and consider himself
the reincarnation
of Zabati Zebi. Okay, so he's born into
a Sabatian family. He's born into a
family that follows the teachings of um
Zab Zebi. Even though Zab Zebi is
considered a heresy even though he's
considered an enemy of the rabbis um
he's born into his family and he and he
will start to extend and systemize the
teachings of Sabbu successful okay he
will have a lot of followers but much
more importantly he will become friends
with European nobility the royal
families of Austria and Russia
his followers will become product
members of the European uh nobility. Uh
they will become very important
intellectuals and they will become very
important bankers. And what I will show
you is they've really gone on to conquer
the world. And so the question for us is
how did he do that? How did he uh
inspire his followers to go conquer the
world? And
um he did so by presenting a new
philosophy, a new religion, okay, that
goes against the Jewish religion. It's
not Jewish uh Judaism, okay? He doesn't
considers himself a Jew. In fact, he
hates Jews. So his new religion called
Sabatian Frankism goes against the
Jewish faith. Okay? And it is a faith
based on success.
And his argument is this. Jesus came to
our world to teach us that the world is
a corpse, right? The material world
doesn't matter. What matters is the
divine spark in you because the divine
spark will set you free. Divine spark
will allow you to return to the moon.
That's what matters. Okay? We're here
just to learn spirituality. We're here
to learn wisdom through pain and
suffering. Then Jacob Frank, okay? Then
look, thinks about this and says, "Well,
you know what? If God is forgiving, if
God wants here wants us to come here to
learn wisdom, why do we have to suffer?
Why can't we become kings ourselves? Why
can't we break the rules of this world,
cheat, hack the system, and become kings
ourselves?" Because isn't that a much
more better way to enjoy our time here?
Okay. And so what he will do is he will
teach this philosophy, this religion to
his followers and he will also train and
teach his followers on how to master
this world, how to conquer this world.
Okay. So we will look at his teachings.
All right. So um we know
um what he says because a lot of things
he said were written down down by his
followers in Polish. And we are now now
going to read a translation by Harris
Lowitz from the univers of UDO. Okay,
these are his words. But what's
important to keep in mind is that these
are words just for the public. Okay, so
we don't actually have access to his
secret mystical magical teachings, the
the the cabala. Okay. Um and think of
what his teachings almost like the
prince. It's a guide on how to conquer
the world. And in fact, the fragrance
will go on to conquer the world. Okay.
So we're going to study his mentality,
okay? his teachings and I'm telling you
right now that he is a brilliant teacher
and the reason why is that he's going to
tell
teach religion teach ideas through
telling stories. He's a storyteller. The
power of stories is that they're like
seeds that embed in your mind. They grow
over time. They become like oak trees,
these massive um trees that shape the
way you see reality and the way you see
yourself. Okay. So the so stories are
the most powerful mechanisms
of education in the world. Okay. So um
Alan can you read the story please?
>> Yeah.
>> One Saturday I went outside the city and
there brought myself some orange and
having a pang knife on me peeled them a
learned Jewish scholar came along with
his purpose. Why are you doing this by
God? Don't you know that today is a
knife on you? You are right. I answered.
You speak the truth, but why are you
such a learned man carrying a knife with
you? How can that be? [clears throat]
shouted the Jew. It is my habit to
bath on Friday and put on different
clothing for the Sabbath. Well, since I
said so, reach into your pocket, and you
will find a knife there for sure. The
Jew was stricken by fear when he, having
put his hand into the pocket, brought
out his own pen knife. He cried out in
amazement, "You cannot be a man, for if
you are a man, then I am an ass." And he
began to beg me to come to him,
promising all kinds of good things, but
I did not want to do it. And in this
way, I did similar things whenever I
could. Okay. So certain things that you
will notice about the story is first of
all, he has contempt for Jews. Okay. A
learned Jewish scholar. And what he
shows is that it's very easy to trick
these people. Why? Because they're
learning their laws have made them
stupid. Okay? They're very strict about
following the laws. And so they become
very ignorant.
And what he also shows you is how to
control people. You control people by
using their own laws against them. Okay?
So this man has a very rigid sense of
the world. He just said to uh Jacob
Frank, hey, you can't use a knife. And
then Jacob Frank is like, well then why
is there a knife in your pocket? And so
it's just a simple magic trick, right?
While he isn't looking, Jacob Frank just
puts a knife into his pocket. It's a
slight of hand. Very simple trick. But
these slight of hands, because people
are stupid and ignorant, you can use
them. You can use these tricks to
control and manip manipulate them. Okay.
So, just because he's able to do this,
the learn Jewish scholar well is now
saying, "Oh, you must be the Messiah.
You must be divine. Let me follow you."
And J was like, "No, you're too stupid
to follow me. Goodbye." Okay. All right.
So, it's a simple story. It's very
amusing. It's memorable. So, if I would
tell you this story, I remember when you
were 6 years old, even when you turned
80 years old, you would still remember
it. And the story will grow over time.
It will shape the way that you see the
world. And what you understand is that
people are fundamentally stupid and and
superstitious. And you must take
advantage of that. Okay. Take advantage
of that because why not? All right.
Okay. Uh Emma, can you read please?
>> Traveling with Zakuboski from Salon Nika
to Poland. There prevailed at that time
a pes
>> pestilence
>> pestilence in po podia. We came to one
township where the plague was feeling
the people and we lacked food, wine,
bread, cheese etc. Then remembering that
from those containment
>> contaminated
>> contaminated with plague one does not
take money I told him the opposite. You
go there purchase everything but don't
give them money. He did just that. He
came to the baker, bargained for bread,
put it in his sack. But when he had to
pay, the baker fell down and died. He
went to the shopkeeper where he
bargained for cheese. He put the cheese
away and the shopkeeper died. He went on
to the store to buy vodka. The same
happened with the owner. In a word, just
wherever he went, he bought everything
without money because the plague was
sweeping the sellers away. coming back
then to me where I was waiting for him.
A rider on horseback knocked him down
with his with with his horse. "What are
you doing?" shouted Jaguoski. "Are you
going to ride right over me?" He didn't
even finish saying it when the riders
toppled over and fell to the ground.
"This is how it is. I did I did all this
because it was promised to me that no
plague, nothing at all, could get at me.
Therefore, all my orders were carried
out successfully by the hand of the one
whom I signed and so should you be.
>> Okay. So, your stories can be
interpreted both literally and
metaphorically. Literally is when people
are are afraid, you take advantage of
their fear. Okay? When people are afraid
to buy things, you go buy things. If
people see the plague, you see as
opportunity to make money for yourself.
Okay? That's a literal. But then the
spiritual is remember Jesus saying that
how the world is a corpse and if you see
it as a corpse you can stand above
people. Okay. And what J is saying if
you see the world as a corpse you can do
whatever you want. You can take
advantage of people. Okay. As long as
you believe that I'm above you okay
you're a dead body. I can take every I
can take everything from you. You will
always triumph. So this is the idea of
justification by sin. How do you know
you truly believe in God? By breaking
the laws of man. By breaking the
convention of man. Because these
convention of man, there's morality,
laws that keep you back. Okay? What
matters is your relationship with God.
You have true faith. You can do whatever
you want. You can conquer the world and
God will let you because you have faith
in God. All right.
All right. Um, can you read out? I asked
Rabbi Isahar and Rabbi Mandach that if
the second belonged to the divine why
did he die. Rabbi Isahar replied to me.
I stand in our book that he came to this
world to experience everything there is.
Therefore he had to come to experience
the bitterness of death as well. That's
fine. And I replied, "The answer is
good. But if he came to experience
everything, why then did he not taste
how it would be to be pasha viza or
sultan? Why did he not experience
rulership? I don't believe it. They
cannot give me any answer to this." And
so this is a great point he makes. Okay,
you have these divine beings like Jesus.
They come to experience the world, to
learn wisdom. And so why do they suffer?
Because suffering is part of wisdom. And
then J Frank's like, "Yeah, but then
isn't being a king also an experience?
Why didn't he become king?" Okay. So
what Jacob Frank is telling you is that
these laws, this morality, religion in
place, it's all a mechanism to control
you, to subjugate you, to enslave you.
Okay? So his is a religion of liberation
from oppression. Okay. Uh keep on
reading Alan.
>> Yeah. That place to where I go all have
knocked so that the door be open to
them. The patriarchs, the Moses, Aaron,
David, Solomon, and all the pillars of
the world. None have been able to open
it. But I will labor and with the
strength of my God will open it. No one
knew but only Balam who knew a little
but he too not well. That which I
mentioned to the company must be
understood concerning those pillars of
the world as was mentioned above. Yeah.
So he's saying the Jewish religion you
worship Moses and David and Solomon. But
you know what at the same time they were
all slaves because they could not see
the truth of this world. They could not
see the true structure of this world.
They couldn't really conquer it. But I
can and I will show you the way as long
as you follow me. Okay. the company um
is his followers and the people who
follow him are called the brothers and
the sisters. So it's very egalitarian
flat hierarchy where there's no it's not
a triangle like most secret societies.
It's just they all obey um Jacob Frank
and Jacob Frank will lead them to
promised land.
[music] Okay.
All right. Uh can you read uh Ember?
>> Should I ri this? Maybe not. Um, in a
dream I saw Jesus having priests around
him sitting at a spring of living and
clean clear water. I noticed that the
spring went away from them and came to
me.
>> Okay, so this is very simple, right? You
think Jesus is the Messiah? Wrong. I'm
the true Messiah. Okay, because the
water flows to me. Life flows to me. Am
I going?
>> I tell you as Christ as you know said
that he came to free the world from the
hands of Satan. But I came to free it
from all loss and status which have been
till now for all that was the work of
the hands of Satan. And by that all fell
into his hands. I must destroy all that
and only make that which is black look
utterly white. At that time the good God
will reveal himself.
>> Okay. So why is it important to sin to
break the laws? Because the truth of the
matter is this world that we live in is
controlled by the false god by Satan.
And therefore a responsibility to resin
to show the world that his laws can be
defied to defy sin himself to show the
world that these laws are idiotic. They
don't make any sense. They're stupid.
Okay? And
by doing that we accelerate the end of
this world. That is an age. When this
world ends we will have a new world when
we'll see the truth for ourselves. When
we will awaken to the falseness of this
world and then we have defeated evil
then we we will have defeated sinner.
Okay this is the idea of accelerationism
right you by sinning you accelerate the
end of the world by sinning you reveal
the truth of the world by sinning you
empower yourself.
Okay.
Okay. Any questions so far?
But you can see how seductive this is,
right? Okay. Um, okay. So, this story is
a bit long. So, so I I'll simp simplify
it. Okay. Again, it is a parable. So,
there's a merchant. He has the world's
most valuable pearl. And he wants to uh
puncture a hole through it because he
wants to create a necklace. And he goes
to all these specialists, artisans, and
they all say, "No, no, no. This pearl is
too valuable. I might break it or I
might damage it. You won't be happy."
Okay? So, they all refuse. the merchant
really wants a hole. So, he offers more
money and everyone's like, "No, I can't
do it." Then this apprentice, okay, and
Jacob Frank's like, "I'm an apprentice.
I don't know anything." He's like,
"Sure, I'll do it." And he does it. And
the merchant IS LIKE, "OH, WOW. THANK
YOU." AND AND the merchant, the
apprentice becomes very wealthy. So, in
this world, what matters is not obeying
conventions, not what matters is not
listening to other people, conforming to
other people. What matters is your
fearlessness. Okay? Just go do it, man.
Seize it and you'll become wealthy.
That's what this world is about. Okay?
We are constrained by these taboss, by
all this morality, by all all this
nonsense. Okay? You you must break
through it and just seize it for
yourself and you'll become powerful.
All right? Okay. This is another story
which is too long, but the story goes
like this. The king has four sons and he
dies. They're all born of the same age.
So he doesn't know. They don't know who
who inherits a throne. Okay. So a great
mystic comes and says, "Okay, here's a
king. This is his body. Shoot an arrow
at his heart and whoever hits the heart
will become king." All three sons try
and miss. The fourth son says, "I can't
do it because he's he is the king. He's
my father. He may be dead, but he's
still my father." And then the wizard,
the mystic says he is your king because
he understands what matters is family.
Okay? So what Jacob F is saying is this.
Everyone else we treat like animals.
They are animals because they're stupid.
They're governed by these idiotic laws.
But we the company, the brothers and
sisters, the family, we have to love
each other. We have to respect each
other even
um in depth. Okay? And our love for each
other is what will allow us to conquer
the world.
[snorts]
All right. Um Allan, can you read me
please? Yeah. There was once a bear.
During its absence, its children were
taken from the lair. Out of the great
pain of not finding the children. When
he came back, the the bear fell upon the
village and wounded animals and people.
The elders of the village sent to it the
following order. If you will not leave
us, then we'll bring two the streaks
together and destroy you. The bear
laughed and sneered at it. They sent the
same message again with a memor
memorandum that will gather four or more
districts. The bear made fun of it
again. Finally, it was sent to the bear
with these words, saying, [music] "In
our village, there are four brothers. We
shall send them against you." When the
bear heard this, it collected itself and
went off on its way. after having
withdrawn from the will right away. So
it is with you I
>> Okay, you understand this? So his
fathers can say to Jacob Frank, "Master,
there's only a thousand of us, but
there's a million of them." And Jacob
Frank is like, "Look, four brothers are
more powerful than 10,000 men." That's
the power of love, right? Jesus taught
us the power of love. D taught us about
the power of love. If we can use it, we
can conquer the world. Okay? We need we
need to harness the power of divine
spark to come together to conquer the
world. It is love that will conquer the
world.
>> All right. Um Emma, can you read please?
>> Holy holy smokes.
>> Okay. No. Um um you know what? This is
too long. Okay. So So I'll just tell
tell you the story. The story is very
simple. There's an elephant. he's
running loose and he's killing people.
So the king um says whoever can kill the
elephant
uh will marry my daughter. So a prince
decides to do this. He disguises himself
as a normal person. And he says to the
king, I will go kill the elephant but
only the condition that you first let me
see your daughter. And the king says
sure why not cuz you're going to die
anyway. And when the prince sees the
princess, the princess recognize her her
right him right away and says, "You must
be a prince. Please don't go out there
and get yourself killed. Marry me." And
the king hears this and says, "If you
are truly a prince, you you don't have
to go go kill the elephant." And the
prince says, "No, no, no. I already
promised you what I will do. Out of my
love for your daughter, I will go and
kill the elephant." And he does. That's
the power of love. Okay? That's what J
Frank is telling you. That's the power
of love. Do things not for money. Do
things not for power, but because of
your love for each other. Okay. That's a
secret to conquering the world.
[snorts]
>> All right. Um can can you read uh Amber?
>> Once while the Sultan was visiting a
slave gallery with his visor, he asked
each slave about his crime. all said
they were innocent of the judgment. Only
one, having revealed his crime, did not
hide anything from the sultan. Why
should this criminal stay stay here with
all these honest people? Shouted the
sultan. Away with him off this gallery
galley. And so the criminal was
released. The visor asked the sultan
about it. "Why do you set him free when
he himself admits to his crimes?" The
king then asked the robber, "What do you
intend to do now?" The robber fell at
the sultan's feet and said, "Oh Lord, if
you will take me into your service, then
surely I will lack nothing, neither
clothing nor robes, and you will see how
devotly I serve you. You will surely be
content with me."
>> Okay, so again, he's teaching his
followers how to conquer the world. And
one thing that you need to understand is
yes, humans are animals, but there's
still good animals and bad animals, and
you [clears throat] need to
differentiate, okay? Animals want to be
loyal. So if you treat a good animal
well, that animal will be loyal to you
forever. Okay. [snorts]
All right. Um can can you read um Alan?
It is a custom during a Jewish wedding
that a distinguished person sit by the
groom. I wanted to beat everyone up so
that this place would be given to me,
but they all spoke up. It is not proper
to try to attain that by fighting, but
by disputation. If you win over them in
a dispute, then it will be proper for
you to sit next to to the groom. I ask
them a few questions and they give me
the answers. This is not a great deal
that you give me the answers because the
SC school teachers taught you that. But
answer me a single questions and that
will be the end. And I ask it stand with
you that the father should circum
circumise
>> circumcise circumcise his child. and
another place it stand that the mother
should circumcise to that they cannot
answers. So I sat down beside the groom.
>> Okay. So the problem with people is that
they're stupid. Okay. And there are lots
of these laws in in the Bible. And if
you just look at the Bible, just read
the Bible, it there's contradictions and
but the Jews believe, oh no, the Bible
is the word of God. But if it's a word
of God, why are there so many
contradictions in the Bible? Okay. And
all you need to do is reveal the
contradictions to the Jews and they'll
just shut up and obey you. Right? So
what he's telling his followers is if
you want to win the world, you you
cannot win the world through violence
and power because there's too many
enemies. Well, if you want to win the
world, you do so through argument,
through learning, by showing the
stupidity of people.
And this is very effective. Okay? So
he's telling his followers, go become
lawyers, man. Go become scholars.
And um at some point in the 19th century
in Warsaw, all the top lawyers in Warsaw
are Frank. Okay?
Because Franken teach you how to think
for yourself, how to think critically.
All right. Um
can you can you read?
Uh Elohim said that
>> Adam is a god. Okay, keep on going.
>> Noise is Adam. Let us make a man. They
wanted to make man higher than his now.
But it was from God himself that Adam
should sing. And so in all ages they
fall until it reached the lowest low
lowness and from among the lowest of the
low as we are our bracement down to the
very bottom. It will be so that our rise
may go on forever upwards and shortly
out of deep darkness the light will
appear us as was said above. That is
exactly what you have yet from signal
sento we shall s thank Adam. Okay. So
the Elohim are gods. Okay. So what he's
saying is that there's hierarchy of
gods. The true god had argument with the
okay. The b is basically saying let's
make men as servants to us. So the man
should be imbued with both spirit and a
bit of flesh. And God says, "No, I want
man to be all flesh, to be all
pleasure." Okay? Why? Because that will
allow men to sin. And the more they sin,
what they will do is learn wisdom and
knowledge. That's a secret to mortals.
Because we can sin, we can learn
knowledge in a way that the gods cannot.
And so the more we sin, the more
knowledge we have. That's why it's
important to sin. If you do not sin and
just follow the laws of men, you'll just
stay stupid. Okay? But if you really
want to understand the world, break the
rules.
The law says don't go and steal from the
storm. Why not try it? See what happens
to you. The worst is that you'll be
fine, right? Or you go to jail for a day
or 10 days, whatever. Okay? But it's
it's knowledge. It's true knowledge that
God cannot give you. That's why God
created us to do things that he cannot
do. Right.
All right. Uh can you read uh Amber?
If you would have held on to her by that
golden thread, as was indicated before,
that with her is the power of leading
you before that big brother who is the
king of kings, or to lead him down to
you together with his brothers and his
whole household, so that the whole
company could see him as I promised to
show you God so that everyone
individually would have the power of
asking him for three things. Then we
would be united with him and at the time
we would go out in freedom from
everything that is from death,
subjugation etc etc as we said above.
>> Okay. So something to understand about
the religion is the messiah is actually
Jacob Frank's daughter Eva. Okay. So the
messiah is a woman. That's the first
thing. Second thing is that there's an
esquetology in this religion. At the end
of days when all the world ends we have
eternal life. Okay. So um in most
religions it's when we die we become
spirit. But Jacob Frank is like why
would we want that? Why would we want to
be like a floating spirit in space? We
can't feel any pleasure. True pleasure
is to enjoy life to have as much sex as
you want man. Eat as much food as you
want. Get drunk as much as you want.
That's true pleasure. And that's what
the end of days will be like. So when we
have achieved the end of days
the big brother will come. Okay. Big
brother is like this in inter
interdimensional higher god who will
come and give us all the wealth. We'll
be free from death. Okay. So that's what
they believe. We'll talk about this next
week as well. But keep this in mind.
Okay. All right. Um
okay. So this is too long but but let
let me tell the story. So a prince
marries a goddess and they have two kids
and the goddess kills both kids and the
prince gets angry and leaves leaves
leaves her but then they meet again and
the prince gets angry and says why did
you kill our kids and the goddess says
here are your kids and the kids come
back what's happened is that by killing
them they've gone on to other dimensions
to learn wisdom to become strong and
beautiful and so what Jacob Frank is
saying is don't question me Okay, I know
things you cannot possibly know. I can
access different dimensions. I can
access the truth of the world. So when I
do things, it's for the greater good.
But never ever question me.
>> All right. Um, this is actually an
important story. Okay. So, Emma, can you
can you read it, please?
>> When I was little, I was at the place of
an old lord and he had peers of
extraordinarily flavor and smell in his
garden. He gave me some to taste and
some for eating. I asked him, "Do you
have many trees in your garden like this
that give this fruit?" He answered, "I
have a lot of big old trees and a few
young ones." I said to him, "I will
steal fruit from your garden and cut
branches so I can plant them myself in
my own garden." The Lord said, "If you
manage to steal them, then they will be
yours. I won't do anything bad to you
for it. But if I catch you in the
garden, then I will do with you as I
please." That garden was surrounded by a
strong high wall. Taking a long pole, I
measured the height of the wall and
having gathered some lads in the woods,
I had them make a ladder for that
height. Having immediately concluded
that there must be some kind of trick
here trick here. When I got there, I
first climbed up the ladder and I
noticed a long cord lying along the
wall. I concluded immediately uh that
there was some kind of trap, not
threading on the cord at all. I looked
uh I looked for the place where it
ended. And I noticed that at the end of
the cord there hung a pistol attached so
that whoever moved the cord immediately
the weapon would fire and the report
would give a sign. Immediately I caught
hold of the hammer unwounded and have
having emptied the pen, cut the pistol
off the cord and took it for myself.
Then thereafter I ordered my lads to
climb the wall and we stole whatever we
wanted. I cut three branches off his
tree too and carried them off to my
garden. In the morning, the court see uh
the Lord seized and recognized the
theft. Thereafter, he posted a lot of
guards to stand watch in the garden at
night. What did I do? I went with my
boys and we all stood around stood
around the wall and fired guns so that
we did not allow the guards to sleep. I
did I did this for three nights, night
after night, the guards being worn out.
I didn't I didn't go to the fourth
night. The guards settled down to sleep.
Thereafter, I returned with my peasants
and began to steal. That lord sent for
me, but I would go only with one who had
been there at the conversation. When I
got there with him, the noble man began
to get mad at me. Then that uh then that
other said, "But you have such an
agreement and so there was peace between
us."
>> Okay, so this is a really important
story. Okay, so let me explain why.
First of all, it's a rewriting of two
different stories. It's a rewriting of
the story of the Garden of Eden, right?
When God told Adam and Eve, don't eat
the fruit. And what the story is telling
you is telling uh you is that it's not
their fault, it's God's fault. Okay,
that's number one. Number two is it's
also rewriting of the story in um
Augustine's
um confessions. So Augustine is one of
the main architects of Catholic Church.
He writes a story of how when he was
young, he and his friends went to steal
peers from a tree and they stole the
they stole the pierce and then and then
he recognized that oh he did this not
because he was hungry or because the
peers were tasty. It's because he's an
evil person. Okay. And what JF Frank is
saying is
that's a stupid story.
What God wants us to do is to break the
rules of man so we can be more wealthy.
Okay? And this is a story that's also
metaphorical. He's telling his followers
that
God
will not punish us if we break the laws.
Okay? Because God cares about our
creativity. God cares about our
willingness to try new things, to
explore, to test the boundaries. That's
what God wants. So, as long as we do so
and we don't break fundamental laws like
killing other people or hurting other
people that angers God, we'll be fine
always. And I will show you how to do
so. I will show you how to get power and
not quit the laws of man. Don't worry
about morality. Don't about convention
taboos. These are all idiotic things
that doesn't matter. We just made them
up. Okay? What matters is that we gain
more and more power. And I will show you
how to do so through trickery and
through deception. Yes.
>> Do we have a specific time that we can
really do such things so freely and we
are not restrained by laws and such
stuff?
>> Okay look Jacob Frank first of all he's
a cabalist. Okay so he's a mystic and if
you go into the mystical Jewish
tradition they teach you that um the
universe is consciousness. It's
vibrations.
So in other words reality is just a a
hallucination. It's what we imagine it
to be. And so these laws, these taboos,
these uh transgressions, they're all
things we made up. They have absolutely
no relevance to reality. Okay? And so
the reality is that if everyone thinks
these laws exist, but you know they
don't exist, that makes you king. Okay?
So that if you can see this for
yourself, become a king, become a
prince. In fact, you'd be stupid and
weak and ignorant if you did not do so.
If you know for a fact that these laws
are stupid, then break them. Take
advantage of this. Okay? If there's a
gold bar sitting in front of you and you
refuse to take it, it doesn't mean
you're virtuous. It just means you're
stupid.
Right.
Okay. Okay. Can you read uh please,
Alan? Yeah.
>> There is no people like the Jews. They
are like snakes and crocodiles, for
there is no loves at all among them, but
only jealousy, hatred, and concentrate
contention one against another. But it
is by far the worst in Poland.
Therefore, as it stand, the evil will
open from the north. Everything else
will be revealed from there as well.
>> Okay. Okay. Can you can you read this as
well?
>> Yeah. There is one thing that neither
1,000 or two nor 3,000 men could lift
that thing up and you were and you would
be able to lift it very easily with one
hand. Okay. So what is this thing where
a thousand 10,000 men can't live up?
It's convention. It's social convention,
right? It's laws that we agree on. It's
morality. But you see the truth for
yourself because I've taught you the
truth and therefore it's easy for you to
lift it up. Okay? So it's the laws of
man that we have problems defying. But
once you see the truth for yourself,
once you've trained your mind to see
that everything around us is false, then
you become God. You become king. Okay.
Um also what this line tells us um he's
complaining about the Jews, right? Frank
hates the Jews because he thinks that
the Jews have done this upon themselves,
right? Why is it that the Jews get
persecuted everywhere? Why is it that
Jews get masquerade everywhere? It's
because of their silly little mind where
they think that that the law says we can
never convert. Who says so? Because of
these rabbis. These rabbis are human as
well. Think for yourself.
Okay. See the truth for yourself. And
that's what he's teaching his followers.
All right. Um Okay. This is actually a
really important story. So, can you read
it? Uh, Amber,
>> there was a certain rich Jew who loved
all men powerfully and received guests
graciously, not uh
>> begrudging them,
>> begrudging them food or drink.
>> So, this guy is rich, the richest Jew in
the world, and he's generous and so we
should all worship him, right? We all we
should all be grateful to him. We should
all honor him, right? But let's see what
happens. Keep on going.
>> Those he treated said to him that they
greatly loved him. mut mutually. What
does he do? He takes a fat roast goose
and having having dressed in having
dressed it in a shirt and having put it
in a little coffer went in the morning
to his friends who had eaten with him
and asked them for advice saying, "The
peasants have planted a dead child on me
and want me to make an attack uh want to
make an attack on me. What shall I do?"
All of them answered him, "We don't want
to know about it, neither about you nor
that child." He went away from them as
if he were very worried at all.
>> Okay, so he's very rich. He's very
generous to people. And he and he's
asking himself, are they really my
friends or are they being nice to me
just because I'm nice to them, because
I'm wealthy. So he designs a test, okay?
And he's asking for help. And when he
asked for help, he realized that these
friends are going to help him even
though he even though he was very
generous to them. Okay, keep on going.
>> He went to his neighbor who had who was
also wealthy, but they had never had
close relations. He asked him what his
advice might be. He replied to him,
"Dear neighbor, let's go and dig a hole
at the edge of your estate and bury the
ch bury the chest there and put some
boards and other stuff on top of it."
But those who had eaten with him
themselves went and spied out the place
where they buried the chest, and they
themselves went to the to the squire of
that town, reporting to him that
terrible deed. That lord together with
his whole household took himself off and
went to the house of that Jew. Having
arrived there, he ordered the
householder immediately thrown in irons
and ordered the place dug up to find the
child. But to the great surprise of
everyone, when the chest was opened, the
roast goose was seen in the shirt. The
Lord asked what that might be.
Thereafter that Jew replied that it was
to test those who really loved him that
he did it and that I wanted to see if
they were really as kindly disposed to
me as they had said. But I have
concluded the reverse. So if you're very
wealthy, you're nice to people, they'll
think you're stupid and naive and
they'll plot against you.
Okay? That's the reality that you live
in. If you want to become rich, you have
to break the laws of man. You want to
stay rich, you have to be mean to
people. You have to recognize that
people are inherently evil. Okay?
They're animals.
Okay. Um Alan, can you read please?
Yeah. It is written that silver answers
everything. It is not even possible to
draw near God without money. Okay. So,
how do you know you're successful? How
do you know you're happy? Money, right?
Um this story down below, he tells a
story of how he has these followers and
he's well respected. So, now these
normal men are trying to broaden says,
"Hey, why don't we join forces? I'll
give you a million dollars." And he
says, "No, I'll give you a billion
dollars." No. I'll give you a trillion
dollars. No, no, no. Okay? Because what
matters is believe in our mission. Okay?
Our mission is create a new world. Our
mission is is the messianic age. That's
what matters.
Okay. Not the money.
All right. Um so c can you read um Alan?
>> Yeah.
>> Two maidens. Two maiders from Poland
daughters were leaving and wanted to lie
down on the bed. I wanted to have
intercourse with them. At that one non
numa nun came undressed and also lay on
the bed. I lay on the bed. The nun says
to me, Lord Franic, what are you doing?
Indeed I am married. I replied, what of
it? Exposition. That thing was that
thing with the nums was prepared for you
and you do that with them in squares,
tons and streets and that would have
been in an internal praise for you also
that the priest would become you servant
but you did not want it. Okay. So this
is a really important idea. The the idea
is that the reality is constructed
through um a hallucination. Okay,
through our own imagination.
And so everyone is living in someone
else's imagination. These laws were
created by someone else. But what what
this means is that what you can do is
create your own reality. And then when
you create your own reality, then people
will obey your laws. Okay? So think of
the story. This is a nun and she sworn
to uphold uh the the church rules,
right? But all Frank did was undress,
lie to bed and just lay there and
imagine her coming. And she does. She
comes. She undresses and she's lying
beside him and now she's like h I'm
afraid that if I do this I have sex with
this man I will be punished by God and
he's like don't worry about it. Okay. So
the world is what you make of it. The
world is what you imagine of it. If you
train your mind to see the world a
certain way then everyone else will see
the way see the world your way. Okay?
That's what controls the world. The
imagination.
Does that make sense guys? Okay. But you
can see why he's so powerful, right?
Yeah. Yes.
>> But like if I create my own world inside
my head, but I did not tell others or I
did not influence others uh by my
actions, how could I like let others to
follow my world. Okay. So this is
something that a no person cannot do.
Okay. This is someone who has an
imagination can do, right? So think of
an writer. The writer is imagining the
world and writing it down. Okay? And
when you read the book, what happens?
You come into this world. Think of a
television show, right? Television show
is just a reality that someone made up.
When you watch television show, you
think it's real. You come into this
world. Okay? And this is what you can do
as well. If you train your mind a
certain way, but you have to train your
mind a certain way, okay? And you and
how do you train your mind? Through
constant education, through reading,
through dialogue, through debate. And
that's why the frames are so powerful.
Okay? because they're not like a bunch
of robbers. They're people who are
deeply engaged in learning
and exercising their imagination. Right?
Does that make sense? All right. So,
this is really important. So, what's
going to happen is that most of Frank's
followers are Jews. And what they're
going to do is they're going to convert
together to the Catholic religion
because when when they do so, they will
be given more opportunities to grow in
power. Okay? to be patronized by
Catholic uh royalty. Okay. So they
decide to convert together
and but before they do they have a
ceremony to mark their conversion. Okay.
Can can you read Amber? On a night
>> on the night of that day the following
deed took place. The Lord set up a
garden in the courtyard made up of our
people so that no one might dare even to
look through the window. And he himself
went in with the brothers and sisters
undressed nude and also her highness OBM
and ordered all those sc all those
scathered to do so. And after having
taken a little bench, he drove a nail
into the center and set two burning
candles on the bench and hung his cross
from the nail. And so after having knelt
before it mim him knelt before it
himself, he took the cross and bowed,
bowed to the four sides and kissed it.
>> [snorts]
>> then her highness and then everyone he
ordered to do so. After that the sexual
relations uh relations took place
thereafter according to his
determination.
At that one of the women women laughed.
Then at the moment the Lord ordered the
candles p put out saying if they would
let the candles burn they would see what
would happen. And at the time he said
with this deed we go to the naked
things. Therefore it is necessary to go
naked. Okay, this deed is conversion.
Okay, so what they're doing is this.
They're converting to a new religion and
they're supposed to swear loyalty to a
new faith, a new god. But what they're
doing in the ceremony is swearing
loyalty to each other. Okay? Through a
ritual. And this ritual is not sex. It's
a ritual of love where
Jacob Frank is instructing each other on
how to behave in a sexual manner. Okay?
And this is a way to cement a covenant
with each other. And what and what this
does is it empowers everyone to go far
and wide. But no matter how far and wide
you go, remember that we are we still
love each other. And because our love
for each other, we will find each other.
Okay? So he tells a lot of stories of
how these prince goes around the world
in disguise because you have no choice.
Because this world is run by idiots.
this this this w this world it's
governed by idiotic laws and therefore
you must disguise yourself. You must
hide yourself. But remember that we will
always find each other because we know
each other for who we are. Okay? Because
we're bounded by this covenant with each
other. So the thing about the Frankus
that's very annoying or which makes
people hate them is they're always
engaging in this sort of sexual rituals.
They have incest with their children.
They have incest with their daughters.
They do a lot of wife swapping. Okay?
And you may think to yourself, this is
degrading. But if you think about it,
wife swapping, who has a power in the
relationship? It's it's actually the
wife, right? Because before the wife had
to stay at home and she had to like and
she couldn't use her body. But now with
wife wife swapping, she can now meet
other powerful men and control them,
manipulate them. Okay. So the Franks are
an extremely egalitarian people where
there's also women empowerment. Okay.
Does it make sense?
All right. Can you read um uh Amber?
>> August 28th, 1762. Her highness OBM
traveled from [laughter]
>> this place to the Lord.
>> Okay. So they're in Poland. Her highness
is is a daughter, right? Eva. Okay. The
Messiah.
She arrived there the 8th of September,
stayed and on the day of judgment had
sexual relations with the Lord for the
first time. The 18th of October, the
Lord said to her, "Now you have beca be
you be become pregnant pregnant by me
with a son." When she came to the Lord
for the first time, the Lord began with
her that ceremony that King Asworth did
with Esther at which she was mightily
frightened. Okay, so this is incest and
the goal of this incest is um for Jacob
Frank to create another body to
reincarnate. Okay, so they believe in
reincarnation. So even though Jacob
Frank, he's really um the last iteration
of S Zebi, it's he's the last one we
know about. Okay, there must be there
must be someone else as well. Okay. Um
so
what do you think Frank and S Zevi
represent is a more powerful
understanding of faith. Okay so remember
there are there have been three
different understandings of faith. The
Catholics believe in the idea of
justification by works. If you just do
what the church tells you to do. If you
avoid sin you go to heaven. Martin
Luther says that's stupid. Um the church
doesn't have authority to decide who
goes to heaven. So he used the idea of
justification by faith. It's only if you
truly believe in God
that you can go to heaven. But the
question is like how do you really
believe show you believe in God? And
what Zevi and Jacob Frank says like by
sinning by going into laws of men by
being shunned by your community by being
hated by your community. That is true
faith in God. And when you do this when
you sin not only do you learn knowledge
but your faith grows more powerful.
And those who understand this, we are a
forever community. We are the true
prince of the world. We are the true
leaders of the world. And together we
will rule the world together. And guess
what guys? They succeeded.
All right? Why? Well, because look, at
the end of the day, the Frankus, they're
a secret organization and they figured
out how to create the most resilient,
the strongest organization in the world.
Okay. So these are are the
characteristics of a really strong
organization. You know hierarchy. So
everyone's loyal to Frank. Okay. Uh unit
of purpose. They're all loyal to Frank.
Selflessness. They all love each other.
Relentless pursuit of material victory.
They love money. Secrecy, discipline,
energy, and motivation. Okay.
Self-hatred, fear, anger, jealousy.
Okay. And selfhatred, fear, anger, and
jealousy is is is um created by sinning,
right? Because when you have sex with
your own daughter, when you do this sort
of stuff, you feel tremendous guilt. But
this guilt can be channeled to make you
more energetic, to make to make you more
focused on success, to make you want to
achieve the end of days. Does that make
sense? [snorts]
All right. So again guys, pregnant is
not Judaism. These are two different
things. In fact, pregnant is a rejection
of Judaism. Okay? Because in Judaism,
they teach you about the spirit. Well,
for Frank, the spirit doesn't matter.
What matters is is the material because
the spirit doesn't allow you to access
wisdom. It's the material that allows
you to access wisdom. Sinning allows you
to access wisdom. Um, Jews tell you to
obey Yahweh. And Frank says, "No, no.
What matters is we defeat Satan here on
earth." Okay, that's the true mission.
Defeat Satan.
Um, Jew says, "Trust God." All right, so
the idea is don't worry about the
Messiah coming.
uh eventually he'll come and he'll lead
us back to Jerusalem and he'll bring us
all back and he'll build a third temple.
And Frank says, "No, no, no. Let's not
wait. God doesn't want us to wait. God
wants us to seize the day. God wants us
to make our own world. That's why God
created us because we have the capacity
to create our own world, our own
paradise. So let's do it. Let's not
wait." Okay? So he's an accelerationist.
Okay? And you do that by sinning a lot,
by showing the fakeness of this world,
that this world is ultimately an
illusion. Okay. So, does this make sense
to you guys?
>> Mhm.
>> All right.
All right. So, um, one thing that you
guys need to know is that it is rumored
that Frank, he's actually the true
founder of the Illuminati, which is an
alliance societies that control the
world today. Okay. So the Frank is what
they will do is when they convert to
Catholicism they will have access to
both uh the Jewish faith Islamic faith
as well as the Jesuit faith the Catholic
faith okay they will combine all three
together because they have spies
everywhere that allow these different
secret societies to coordinate. Okay so
there's a rumor that um Frank thought
the Ilamati but I suspect he did. Why?
Because one of the most famous members
of the Illumin Illuminati is Gerta.
Okay. And Gerta wrote a very famous uh
play called Foust. And let's think about
the plot of Foust. The plot is this. You
have FA scholar. He's looking for
wisdom. So he makes a deal with Messets
the devil and says and Methus says I
will give you eternal wisdom in return
for your eternal life, your soul. And
Paul says sure okay. And false does a
lot of things. He sins. He has sex with
a young child. She dies. He does a lot.
He does a lot of really bad things. But
he learns a lot of wisdom. And when he
dies, he's supposed to go to heaven.
That's right. When he dies, he's
supposed to go to hell. Okay. But at the
very last minute, when the has come to
claim his soul, God sends angels to
rescue fouls and take him away. Okay?
That's a very frankest attitude towards
life. Sin as much as you want in order
to gain wisdom. If you do so, if you
gain a lot of wisdom, then God will
reward you with eternal life. Okay?
All right. Um, again, the Franks
infiltrate the Jesuits. And so, a lot of
people believe that the Franks now
control the Catholic Church or have a
lot of say over the Catholic Church.
Okay.
Um, okay. They also infiltrate the
Freemasons. I'll show you this next
class. Okay.
They also um they're also a major
influence on development of Mormonism.
Okay, if you look at the structure of
the Mormon church and you look at
Frankenism, it's very similar
Scientology guys. Okay, if you just look
at Scientology, it's very similar to the
Frankus belief as well.
All right, some very famous uh Frankus
in history. Look, there's lots of them,
okay? Um but it's all secret because
they work in silent. The big thing is
their secrecy among their secrecy. Okay,
they go in silence. But we know for a
fact that Louis Bandis who is the first
Jewish
Supreme Court justice in America he was
a Frankus and there's a very famous
university Brendai University found it
after him. Okay. So if you think that so
if you know that this guy is a Frankus
think about how many other very powerful
Americans are also Frank. Okay. I'm not
allowed to name their names because
well they would deny it and I I I would
get in a lot of trouble if I if I
mentioned their names but they are very
powerful people and you know who they
are. Okay you you will know their names
but you may not know their frankus.
Um this is William Butler Yates who is a
very famous Irish poet. He himself also
is me member of secret society. Okay.
And we're going to read a poem together
by Yates to show you the influence of
Cracker's philosophy on modernity. In
fact, what I will show you next class is
you can make the argument that Jacob
Frank and sometime Zebie together they
created modernity in the west. All
right. So, we're going to read a poem by
this very famous Irish poet who was also
a Nobel Prize winner, also a member of a
secret society called the Order of the
Golden Dawn. Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. So, it's called Crazy Jane
Talks with the Bishop. Okay. So, uh
Emma, can you read please? Very simple.
>> I met the bishop on the road. Emma said
he and I.
>> Okay. So, this is a woman and he's she's
talking to a bishop, right? A high
religious authority. Keep on going.
>> Those breasts are flat and fallen now.
And fall fallen now. Those veins must
soon be dry. live in a heavenly mansion,
not in some foul sty.
>> Okay? So, you're fallen, right? So,
you've sinned a lot in life. You've
lived a terrible life. But don't worry,
God is forgiving. If you convert, if you
um change your life now, God will
forgive you. All right? And all be good.
Keep on going, Amber.
>> Fear and foul are near of kin, and fear
needs foul, I cried. My friends are
gone, but that's a truth. nor grave nor
bed denied. Learned in bodily loneliness
and in the heart's pride.
>> You cannot have [clears throat]
sin. Sorry. You cannot have good without
evil. You cannot have ugliness. Uh you
cannot have beauty without ugliness.
Okay. So, and this is something that
I've learned because I've sinned because
I've gone low.
Okay. Keep on going.
A woman can be proud and stiff, one on
love intent. But love has pitched his
mansion in the place of excre excrement
excrement. For nothing can be soul or
whole that has not been rent.
>> Where is God? Where is love? God is in
garbage. Okay? So you have to sink low
to truly find God. You have to sink low
to truly find yourself. you have to
destroy yourself in order to truly
create yourself.
Okay? And that is a very practice
attitude. So in many ways, Frank's
belief has conquered
um modern western culture. And I will
show you why next class. Okay, any
questions?
Like [clears throat]
I think Frank said that you can have all
pleasures that you want of sins but I
think that is a kind of low vibration so
we need to have that low vibration and
sins to learn our mistakes so we can
find the success right okay um look
sin
is taboo okay it's barriers it's the is
walls in front of
But if you really want knowledge, you
have to break through these walls so
that reality can re reveal itself more
clearly to you. Do you understand? Sin
are all these invisible walls that you
put in front of you for no particular
reason. It's all part of your
imagination.
Okay. So if you want to see the world as
it truly is, if you really want to see
yourself for who you truly are, then you
must sin. Because sin will also cause a
process of guilt and reflection
and wisdom. Okay? It will cause another
process of pain and suffering.
And we avoid sinning because we're
afraid of social condemnation. We're
afraid of being laughed at. We're being
afraid. We're afraid of being mocked by
other people. But if you really want
true knowledge, you have to go against
social conformity.
Okay? Does that make sense? Okay. So,
sin, don't sin just for the sake of
sinning. Sin because it allows you to
access greater knowledge, a deeper
knowledge. Okay. Does that make sense,
guys?
>> All right. Any more questions? Yeah.
>> Do you think that the that the Francis
ideology has an impact on the uh the
Palestine
uh Israel conflict? Cuz I think I see a
lot of um
similar narratives coming in. Yeah.
[clears throat] So at the very end of
the course I will teach you like the sub
between Frankus they're the founders of
Israel.
>> Oh okay.
>> Yeah. So what's happening in Palestine
in Israel today it's driven by the Frank
philosophy. Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you. Okay.
>> Any more questions?
Okay. Great. So, I'll see you guys next